(authoritative music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a professor of economics
at Brown University,
a distinguished fellow
of the American
Economics Association,
and a member of the U.S.
Council on Foreign Relations,
Glenn Loury.
Welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks, Dave.
Good to be with you.
- How'd I do on the bio there?
You have quite an extensive bio.
I've got the whole thing here.
I left off like 10 things
that probably could have
been the lead thing.
- Well, I'm a member-
- Was that all right?
- I'm a member of the American
Philosophical Society.
I'm kind of proud of that
because those are
the guys that write,
and the girls, that
write the big books,
and I don't know why they
included me in their number.
I haven't written any big books,
but the American
Philosophical Society.
- All right, there you go,
so before we get
to anything else,
I wanna ask you about that shirt
'cause you flashed me something
right before we started,
straight outta quarantine.
Are you a free man in a
free country right now?
- (chuckles) Well, I have
contracted, been treated for,
and recovered from COVID-19,
knock on wood, thank God,
so yeah, I mean, it's a,
my wife bought
this shirt for me.
It's kind of a play
on the old hip-hop rappers,
"Straight Outta Compton,"
so I'm straight outta quarantine
and glad to be free at last.
- (chuckles) Free at last.
Well, actually,
let's start there.
I wasn't planning
on doing too much
kind of COVID-related
stuff to you,
but what do you make
out of what has happened
in the last year related
to COVID and lockdowns?
And then, I think some of that
will probably get us into
some of the social
issues of the day,
which is what you're
talking about a bit more.
- Treacherous waters
that you're inviting
me into there, Dave.
You could say the wrong
thing and get canceled.
I mean, a number of things
come to mind.
- Don't worry.
Nobody's been canceled 'cause
of me. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- (laughs) I'm a
social scientist,
so the first thing
I think about is
what are the kinds of studies
that people are
gonna do for years
assessing what happened here?
And there are many
dimensions to it.
There's the public
health dimension to it.
There was a
pandemic, a pathogen.
It spread in the
population. People died.
How effective were the
various responses to that:
shutdowns, masking,
and stuff like that,
but I think there are also
some political things here.
For example, Donald Trump
was hated by a lot of people.
They hung this around his neck.
Now, maybe he didn't
handle it as well...
I think I'll retract the maybe.
He didn't handle it
as well as he could
have handled it, okay?
On the other hand,
here was an opportunity
to sink Donald Trump,
and I think a lot of
people seized on it,
so one of the interesting
political questions to me is
how did the partisan
character of American politics
and the role the
media plays in that
affect the way that
this thing was reported?
But there are many,
many dimensions to it,
so the social
pressure to conform,
you know, have you
been vaccinated?
And I'm for getting vaccinated.
I've been vaccinated myself.
I'm not against
being vaccinated.
Tucker Carlson, whom I
follow from time to time,
is on a tear about
the masking stuff,
and there is a real
question there.
I mean, the government
is gonna tell me
what I have to put on my face.
That works maybe in an
absolute emergency situation,
but when that becomes
a way of life,
you have to start
asking the question
about individual
freedom and so on,
so there's just many
different pieces to it
that I expect will be
examined by serious people
for years to come.
- Yeah, was there
anything that shocked you
just about the general
way, not the media,
but just the way
people sort of became
so hyper-partisan about a virus,
meaning that the mask has
become sort of I'm a Democrat;
the non-mask is
I'm a Republican,
something like that,
sort of loosely speaking.
- Well, that's one aspect of it.
I mean, and some people were
just absolutely terrified.
I mean, they wouldn't
come out of their houses.
They had their groceries,
they would wipe down
everything with a cloth,
and I thought that
was over the top.
I thought that was excessive,
but then, how do we handle risk?
Everybody is gonna
react to it differently,
so what I was saying
to my friends was
if you told me there was
a one-in-a-thousand chance
that I would die if I
stepped from my front door,
I might stay inside for
a week, maybe two weeks.
After that, I take my
chances. You know what I mean?
So don't impose your
risk preference on me.
That was kind of my...
And I'm like, "It
takes two to tango,"
so if I wanna have
a dinner party,
and the people don't wanna
show up, what can I do?
But I did feel
that there was a
lot of over-the-top
kind of overreaction
to schools staying
closed and whatnot.
I'm not an expert on the
data about school closings,
but my colleague Emily Oster is,
at Brown University's
economics department.
Look her up. She had a piece
of "The New Yorker" about this.
She is an expert.
She's a liberal.
She's a liberal, and they
just tried to tear her apart
because she said
schools should open up
because she said the
data don't justify
keeping the kids away
from the classroom.
You're doing more harm
than you're doing good.
The cure is worse
than the disease.
Where did I hear that
before? She said it.
She said it, and they
tried to take her head off,
so it was really,
really a very interesting and
very pathological situation
from the way in which we
made decisions as a society.
I think politics, fear,
panic, groupthink,
these were all at play.
- What do you consider
yourself politically?
Do you specifically say,
"I'm this, I'm that,
I'm the other thing"?
'Cause when I'm
listening to you,
I sense a little
bit of everything,
which, by the way,
that's probably how
most people really are.
We just get hung up
on the labels.
- Okay,
so I'm a registered independent.
I don't tell people how I vote.
What I was telling them
during last year's
presidential election is,
"Of course I voted for Biden.
"What else would you
expect me to say?"
And then I'd laugh,
and I'd say, "I can't
say anything else."
You still don't
know who I voted for
if I tell you I voted for Biden
'cause if I voted
for the other guy,
I'd never tell you
I voted for him,
but I'm a conservative.
I think I just have
to admit that now
on a number of
different dimensions.
I'm an economist, and
I lean neoliberal.
I lean toward open
markets, and free trade,
and letting the
prices do their work.
I don't like the Green New Deal
because these people wanna
absolutely run our economy
on behalf of their vision about
how the future should look,
and that terrifies me.
I think taxes are, generally
speaking, too high.
I think regulation can go,
often does go over the top
and impedes our prosperity.
I think the way
forward has been shown
by capitalism with a C,
capitalism not with
a K, et cetera,
so that makes me somewhat
of a conservative.
I write a lot about
racial issues,
and I'm cutting against
the grain there.
I think the country
has lost its mind
with this diversity
and inclusion stuff.
I'm not a big fan of
affirmative action.
I think reparations would
be an absolute disaster
for this country as well
as for African Americans.
We could talk about it,
so they call me a conservative,
and I'm not fighting
with them about it.
- Yeah, I hear you,
and I think what you
just said right there
sums up what most of my audience
probably is at some level,
whether some are maybe a
little more libertarian,
or a little more
traditionally conservative,
or whatever it is,
but you just gave me
a great sort of lead
on everything else
I wanna talk about
because one of the things
that I wanna talk about is
we hear this phrase systemic
racism all the time,
and I've heard you
talk about this.
I've read some of
your stuff on this.
In some ways,
we're just not all talking
about the same thing
when we say the phrase
systemic racism,
so can you lay out maybe
what you believe it to mean
versus what you think some
other people think it means.
- Okay, in the simplest terms,
here's what I think
people are saying.
They're saying back
in the old days
of the civil rights movement,
Civil Rights Act of 1964,
Martin Luther King,
and all of that,
the issue was racist treatment,
unequal treatment of people,
discrimination in
housing, and jobs,
and credit markets, and so on.
Blacks weren't treated the same.
They were discriminated against,
and the goal was
equal treatment,
which is why King
is there saying,
"I have a dream that
my kids will be judged
"by the content of
their character."
He doesn't want them
discriminated against.
He doesn't want them kept from
voting 'cause they're black.
He doesn't want them
kept from shopping
because they're black.
He wants them to be
treated like anybody else.
That's the old school thing.
Systemic racism is declaring
there to be a new day
because, guess what?
We pretty much have solved
the discrimination problem.
Not completely, but
just about as completely
as you could solve
it in a free society.
Every state has an
Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission.
There's a ton of lawsuits
that you can bring
against your employer
if you think you're not
being treated fairly.
God help a retailer if he
actually does discriminate
and charge a different price
to a black customer, right?
So-
- Which we would all be against,
just to be very clear.
- Yeah, we're against that.
That bit has been solved,
but the disparities
are still there, okay?
Blacks are overrepresented
amongst the incarcerated,
underrepresented amongst the
students at a fancy college,
have lower wealth holdings,
et cetera, et cetera,
so the disparities are there,
but the account
of the disparities
that black person was
discriminated against
is no longer very effective
as an explanation,
so people are calling
on larger forces,
not personal, one-on-one
historical forces.
I mean, here's an example:
New Orleans floods.
Black people, on average, live
at lower level, sea level,
so they get flooded worse.
They get flooded worse
'cause they're poor.
They get flooded worse,
maybe because in the
history of New Orleans,
I don't know anything
about it specifically,
but this is just a hypothetical,
they were discriminated against,
and the high-ground
housing wasn't as easily,
those neighborhoods weren't the,
real estate agents didn't
show them, whatever, whatever.
They got worse jobs, et cetera,
so they're on the lowland,
so then the flood comes
and they're discriminated.
Now, some of us would think
that's an unfortunate
act of nature,
and that, just like
if a pandemic comes,
and you got more comorbidities
and pre-existing conditions,
you're going to
get a harder hit,
but it's not an act of
racism, a person might say,
but the systemic racism people
wanna say, "Oh, no, no, no.
"It is an act act of racism.
You see that disparity.
"The history of race in America
"is what has made that
disparity happen."
Then they have their story.
In this case,
the blacks are in the low-lying
neighborhoods in New Orleans
because of discrimination
in the past, and racism,
and so that's their story.
Mass incarceration
is racist. Why?
Because, well, the drug
laws are what they are,
and they wouldn't
be what they are
if the people who
were being locked up
were mostly white people,
and they have their accounts.
There are not enough
blacks at Caltech. Why?
Because of systemic racism
in the education
system, and so on,
so it's an effort to
explain disparities
in the absence
of individual racist
discriminatory acts.
That's how I understand it.
- So I'm guessing,
well, of course you know of and
probably know Thomas Sowell,
but the book "Discrimination
Versus Disparities,"
I mean, he goes into this a lot,
so what do we do about
the disparity stuff?
For those that understand
what you're saying,
they're saying, "Okay,
the system's not racist,"
meaning there are no racist
laws against black people,
but that wanna acknowledge
that these disparities exist.
Where do you start
with the disparities?
'Cause we seem, we
can't even get there.
- Well, if you
follow Thomas Sowell,
I do know him, not that well,
although I've just joined
as a senior fellow at
the Hoover Institution,
so I'm gonna get
to know him better.
- I'll add that to
the bio for next time.
- I just signed on.
I haven't even been, set
foot on the campus yet,
but I'm looking forward to it.
- Nice, that's awesome.
- But if you follow
Thomas Sowell,
he would say it's a
fool's errand to think
that you're ever gonna get
rid of all the disparities.
He would say, "Look at the
ethnic Chinese in Indonesia,
"and the Philippines,
and Southeast Asia."
He says, "Look at them.
They're businesspeople.
"They are wealthier. They
are better educated."
He would say, "Look
at the Sinhalese
"and the Tamil in Sri Lanka."
He would say, "Look at the
Lebanese in West Africa."
Jews pretty much everywhere."
He would say, "There is
no absence of disparity."
The story of ethnic
history is disparity,
so if you set for yourself
the goal of getting
rid of disparity,
all right, this puts
it a little sharply,
but I think it's not inaccurate,
you're buying into tyranny
because the only way
to get rid of disparity
is to force things to be equal
when the natural
state of affairs
would not have things be equal.
What would getting rid of
disparity in the NBA mean?
Or the NFL?
I mean, well, know
what it would mean.
It would mean a lot of
Chinese point guards,
and it would be a
lot less interesting.
That's a cheap shot, I know.
I mean, that was
easy for me to say.
- You're going to my weakness.
- But the point stands.
- Man, I got a basketball
right behind me.
45 with a blown-out
ACL in my left knee,
but that's what I'd
rather be doing than this.
- Oh, okay. You were good, huh?
- I was all right, yeah.
- In your day.
- All right, so
Sowell would say,
"Don't expect that there's
not gonna be disparities."
I would agree with that,
but I would go further.
I don't think that...
If I don't like
disparities, get busy.
This is what I wanna say to
my fellow African Americans.
You don't like the disparities?
You don't like the wealth
gap? Start a business.
You don't think there's
enough black engineers?
Okay, let's study some calculus.
Let's get some kids together.
We'll do it on the summer.
We'll have a summer camp,
and we'll do a
bootcamp on calculus.
Kid that can do the
integral equation fastest
will get a star on his thing,
and whatever, whatever.
All right, get busy.
Disparities don't
have to be destiny.
Just because there's a disparity
doesn't mean that we have
to accept it as given
if, indeed, we want better for
ourselves and for our people,
but don't be looking
outside of the community
for society, or white
people, or whatever
to solve that problem for you,
especially when our
families are in disarray,
especially when the
behavior of some people,
a few in our communities,
makes life absolutely impossible
for anybody else
to function there
because of the violence,
and the chaotic
behavior, and whatnot,
especially when the
TV can be turned off
and the kid could be directed
to do his homework, or hers.
That's a part of the
parental responsibility,
et cetera, et cetera.
I don't mean to be
putting people down.
I just mean to say our
fate, this is my argument,
is substantially
within our own hands,
so if you don't like the
disparities, get busy.
- Disparities aren't destiny.
That's a title for a book
right there. You got it.
That's the next book
you gotta write.
Within all that, you're
talking about the family,
and then Sowell
also talks about how
when the welfare state
really kicked in in the '70s,
that, in essence, it blew
apart the black family,
but even talking about this,
people will not be kind.
- Yeah, well, you've
got two things going.
You got feminism,
so what I mean is
you have a revolution
in political-social attitudes
around the roles of women
and about the sort of legitimacy
of conventional
two-parent arrangements
and stuff like that,
so I don't wanna just
put it all on the women.
The sexual morality
ideas have changed,
gay rights and stuff like that.
I mean, it's a different world
than it was 50 years ago,
and that has worked
against, I think,
the job of mending
the black family.
I'd put it in those terms.
People will get upset,
but what I mean is
if 70% of kids, babies
born to a black woman,
are born to a woman
without a husband,
this is not a healthy state
of affairs for the community.
That has consequences
in terms of the human
development of those youngsters.
Boys need fathers.
Girls need fathers too.
Adolescent boys with
the testosterone flowing
need discipline.
They need fathers.
They need examples
of what it means
to live rightly as
a man in the world.
In the absence of that,
you're gonna get the kind
of chaos that you're seeing,
so you've got that,
that the social liberals,
the people who wanna
rewrite the rules,
will object to invoking
tradition in this context.
The other piece you've got is
we had a war on poverty,
and poverty won.
That would be, that's
what Charles Murray said
in that classic book of
his, "Losing Ground."
That's what Thomas
Sowell is saying
when he points out the ill
effects of the welfare state,
and on the other side of
that is the Democratic Party,
and the liberal political
establishment, and whatnot,
who believe that the transfers
from the welfare state
could do no harm.
There are no incentive problems.
Now, if you tell a woman
that she can get by on a...
It's not a good living.
Welfare is not a good living,
but it is money
coming from the state,
and you think that that
doesn't affect her behavior.
Well, again, I'm an economist.
Of course, it does
affect her behavior,
so I don't know that
I wanna declare war
on Medicaid or food stamps.
These are established programs.
They're hundreds of
billions of dollars
going out the federal door,
but there are families
that need these benefits.
I think we've gone far
enough down this road now
that it's hard to
imagine going back,
but if, as a
historical analysis,
I think part of the weight
has to be laid at the feet,
the weight of the structure of
African American family life
in the year 2021
has to be laid at the feet
of those who didn't listen
when they were warned
about the ill effects
of transfer programs on the
incentives that people had,
so yeah.
- So yeah,
so speaking of those
who didn't listen,
you mentioned the
social liberals.
Now, I'm guessing
at Brown University,
politically, you
are an outsider.
You're surrounded by
a lot of liberals,
although I wouldn't say
they're old school
liberals at this point.
You're probably surrounded,
really, by a bunch of leftists,
but do you find
that some of your old
school socially liberal,
say, classical liberal
colleagues, if any remain,
kind of on the DL are like,
"Yeah, Glenn, you're right
about all this stuff,
"but, you know, I don't want
them showing up at my house."
- Yes, not quite those words,
but pretty much that attitude.
A lot of people...
I mean, there's a lot of
different stuff going on.
Some people are religious,
and they're in the closet.
They actually believe
in God. They pray.
They read the Bible, and
they won't talk about it.
Some people have misgivings.
They're not sure, but they
know that the wind is blowing
so strong in the
other direction,
but I'll tell you,
I've been encouraged by some
of my students here at Brown,
which is notorious for being
an ultraliberal bastion,
and certainly we've
got plenty of that,
but there are
students around here
who are hungry for
something different,
and I've found them coming
to some of my classes,
and coming around to
talk to me privately.
I'm not saying that they would
have voted for Donald Trump.
They would've never done that.
I'm not saying that
they're pro-life.
They're not; they're pro-choice.
They're pro-gay marriage
and all that kind of stuff,
but I am saying that
they find some of the concerns
that I've been expressing
around these issues
to resonate with them,
and some of them are religious,
and they will come,
and they will say,
and I must say, I'm
not myself, personally,
a professing Christian
at this point in my life.
I used to be very strongly.
I was baptized at the age of 40.
It's a long story. I'll
tell it in my memoir.
Stay tuned, but
I'm open to people
who are overt about
expressing their faith,
and I have deep respect
for this challenge
that we all face
as sentient beings
of contemplating the ultimate
questions of existence,
and there are no easy answers
to those ultimate questions,
so I find that in
some of my students.
I'm just saying Brown
is not one thing.
We have a reputation,
deservedly so,
but it's a complicated and
interesting community here,
and I do find like minds,
both amongst my
colleagues and students.
- Yeah, even though
I'll let you save that
story for your memoir,
but do you find
that there is some sort
of spiritual awakening?
I've sort of sensed that
because the progressive movement
has just become this
secularism on steroids,
government everything monster,
that an awful lot of people,
and I would include
myself in this,
who are not
traditionally religious,
are finding answers
in different ways.
- Well, I hope that's right.
I just gave you my report
about what's going
on here at Brown.
I can't speak beyond that,
but I hope that's right.
- Yeah, interesting.
All right, so let's move on
to some of the other things.
Well, first off,
according to my paperwork
here, you're black.
Is that, is that...
- (chuckles) Last time
I checked I'm black.
I was born in Chicago,
1948, on the South Side.
My mother and father were
also born in Chicago.
They were black. I'm black.
- Okay, so as a black man
that's a professor at
a liberal university,
I unfortunately end up having
to ask all of my black guests,
or I would rather say guests
who happen to be black
that are doing something
sort of similar to
what you are doing,
can you just talk a little bit
about the type of
treatment you get?
Not from some of
the good students,
but just sort of from the,
say, antiracist crowd,
'cause they're not
that thrilled with you.
- (sighs) You know, I'm
probably the wrong guy to ask.
I mean, I'm 72 years old, okay?
I know it doesn't
show, but it's true.
Born in 1948,
so I'm a senior member
of the community.
I've been around for a long
time. I'm a known quantity.
I have the various
accolades that I have.
I've had a distinguished
career as a research economist.
I don't think people really
tell me what they think
or react to me...
It may be certain
deference to my position
and to my senior status.
It may be out of respect for
my academic accomplishments.
I hold a chair here
at Brown, et cetera.
I think they may whisper
out of my earshot this or that,
but I don't feel the chill.
Now, COVID, COVID has
had an impact here
because we're not
coming face to face.
We're meeting through
Zoom, and Skype, and such,
and this last year
has been a year
in which some of my
more conservative ideas,
especially about race,
and diversity, and equity
have come to a head because
of the reckoning about race
in the aftermath of George
Floyd, and all of that.
I've written pieces that have
gotten a lot of positive play
in conservative quarters,
which I'm sure some of
my colleagues despise,
but I'm not seeing them
around the lunch table
at the faculty club,
so that they can convey
their contempt for me
with their glare
or their whatever,
so I don't know
about the last year,
but before that,
I would say it was kind of
like a gentleman's agreement
that Glenn is a curmudgeon.
Glenn is Glenn. Yeah, that's
where he's coming from.
He's not a bad guy.
He's all screwed up
about this stuff,
but that's all right.
We'll still invite
him to dinner,
and I don't know
what's gonna happen
once we get back to
business as usual.
We'll see.
- It's kind of funny
idea for a short story:
a conservative professor
who, because of lockdowns,
can feel more emboldened
because the colleagues
aren't gonna sneer at him
at the commissary or
something, you know?
- Somebody ought to be
working on that story.
- (chuckles) Somebody should be.
Do you sense there's
anything left?
I mean, I get you're
not a Democrat.
I haven't heard you say
you're a Republican,
but I get you're not a Democrat.
- I'm a registered independent
who's playing both sides
of the street, so to speak,
but I'm not very happy
with where the
Democrats are right now.
- Yeah, I mean, do you sense,
is there anything left there
that is in line with the
ideas that you believe in,
that you think is in line
with the ideas of
Martin Luther King?
- The Democrats are nothing
without the black voting 95%,
90% for their candidates.
They would lose control of
everything without this.
Biden wouldn't be
president today
if James Clyburn were not able
to corral enough black votes
at South Carolina's
Democratic Primary
to get him out of the hole,
so here's what I see.
I'm not a professional
political scientist,
so you can take it
for what it's worth.
They're buying black votes
by waving a bloody
shirt of racism.
That's what they're doing.
They're selling this idea
that George Floyd's
death was yet one
of another, of
another, of another
racist state killing
of black people.
There's "Open Season,"
as Ben Crump says in the title
of his book on black people.
Now, black people, be afraid,
be afraid, be very afraid.
White racists are
coming to get you.
They're in your
police department.
They're right around the corner,
and we are the only
thing between you
and a noose around your neck.
That's what they're saying.
It's not the new Jim...
The Georgia voting integrity
law is not just Jim Crow.
"It's Jim Eagle. They wanna
put you all in chains."
That's a quote from
President Joseph Biden:
"They wanna put y'all
back at chains."
Okay, so if black people, I
speak now to African Americans,
if you happen to be watching
"The Dave Rubin Report,"
if you fall for
this, we're fools.
If we fall for
this, we are fools.
We're being led around with
a ring through our noses,
so they show nothing but
contempt for black people.
I'm talking about
Joseph R. Biden now.
- I'm with you.
I know my audience is with you,
and I think,
actually, truthfully,
I think most of
America is with you.
We just don't know where
the brave voices are.
I think that's part
of the problem.
I mean, you're one of them,
but I think that we're living
in this bravery
deficit right now.
- These issues, the racial
conflict coming out of slavery,
threaten the existence
of the Republic.
600,000 people in a
country of 30 million
were slaughtered on the
battlefields of the Civil War,
the consequence of which
was the emancipation
of the African slaves.
Here we are now,
150 years later,
and the descendants
of those slaves
are citizens of the
freest, richest,
and most powerful republic
in the history of the world.
- Man, Glenn, you wanna
run for president?
I got it: you're
72, but come on.
Come on, that's young for
a president these days.
- Thanks. I appreciate that.
That's not the burden
I was thinking about
taking up right now.
I was looking for the beach.
I was looking to put my
feet up now. (laughs)
- Fair enough. Fair
enough. (chuckles)
Well, can you paint a way,
or do you see a way out of this?
I think a lot of
people sort of think
we're just in this
endless descent.
We can address the things
that you've addressed.
We could say, "No,
you guys are wrong
"because we have to
talk about disparities
"instead of discrimination.
"We have to define
things properly,"
but I think a lot
of people think,
"Oh, we just can't
stop this force."
- I don't know how it stops.
I'm being honest with you.
I feel like I'm
spitting in the wind.
My little humble efforts
with John McWhorter,
we have a podcast,
"The Glenn Show,"
and we talk about these
things and whatnot.
That's at patreon.com/glennshow,
two N's, one word.
You know...
- We'll link to it, but I
gotta get you on locals.
That's a different topic.
- Oh, okay, but
in any case, man,
I think we had a chance,
with the presidency
of Barack Obama,
to really change the
conversation, and
that he let us down.
We can talk about the
presidency of Barack Obama.
It is many, many things.
It's not just this,
but on this portfolio,
"If I had a son, he'd
look like Trayvon."
He shouldn't have said that.
Shouldn't have said,
"My friend, Henry Gates,
"the police acted stupidly."
We could go through
all these things.
He shouldn't have
made Al Sharpton,
200 times visiting
the White House,
ambassador to black America
from his administration.
He shouldn't have done that.
He should have stood
for law and order
when Baltimore was burning down,
when Ferguson, Missouri
was burning down
instead of splitting
the difference
and saying they have
legitimate grievances.
Of course they have
legitimate grievances,
but it doesn't rise
to the level of arson,
and assault on police
officers, and looting.
That's unforgivable.
That cannot be tolerated.
I don't care what
their grievances are,
and he should have said so.
He should have turned
to black America,
as he tried to do a little
bit during the campaign,
but he beat a retreat from it,
and said, "Yeah, there's
racism, but you know what?
"We need to pull up our socks."
He could have found a
better way of saying it.
He could have found an
Obamaesque way of saying it.
"We need to stand up straight
with our shoulders back,"
as Jordan Peterson could say.
We need to take care of our
kids. We need to get busy.
Racism is not the
first, or the second,
or the third issue
confronting us.
He could have said that.
He could have shut up
some of these people
like Ta-Nehisi Coates.
Instead, he invites them
for cozy talks, et cetera.
Shut them up by saying,
"My occupying this
office, commander in chief
"of the most powerful
military on the planet,
"the agenda-setter for
this great republic
"of 325 million people,
"gives the lie to your talk
about oppressive denial
"of the integrity
of black bodies."
He said it in 2004,
Barack Obama did.
He said, "It's in my very DNA."
He's black and he's white.
We all are,
metaphorically speaking.
There's only one people
here: the American people.
There's only one people here.
For a variety of reasons,
President Obama elected,
and it's not an easy job.
It's a hard job. That's
why I don't want it.
Thanks, anyway, Dave.
- (laughs) I
apologize. I apologize.
- For a variety of reasons,
he elected not to
take that one on,
and he's the only person
who could have taken it on.
He's the only person
who could have sat
in the White House...
You saw what happened
when Trump tried to order
out the National Guard
or whatever it was he
tried to do to deal,
and everybody goes ballistic,
and it's all racist,
and what not.
Obama's the only person
who could have changed
that conversation
by putting his racial identity
and his civic
responsibility on the line,
not as a fealty to the
black victim narrative,
but as an affirmation of the
possibilities of the country.
Now, it's easy for me
to say this, I know,
but that's what I see when
I look at it in retrospect.
An opportunity was missed
between 2009 and 2017,
and where we are now,
I mean, I heard Michelle
Obama, the former First Lady,
say to Gayle King at "CBS
Morning News" the other day
that she worried that her
daughters Sasha and Malia
might be set upon by
rogue police officers
because they're black,
and they might be
mistaken for somebody,
and to that, I have to say this,
I mean, I said this on my
podcast, so I'll say it to you.
First of all, it's
false. It's false.
You gotta get past the Secret
Service to get to those kids.
She knows it's false.
Secondly, she knows that
what she said is untrue,
So what is she doing?
She's playing you Negroes.
She's playing you.
She's enacting a trope,
a narrative in the service
of a political program,
which is to keep you
on the reservation,
afraid that the boogeyman racist
is gonna come and
get your children.
She's not worried about her
children being harassed by,
on Martha's Vineyard,
by a cop because they're black,
so instead of pushing
against this narrative,
which is comforting.
It is a comfortable place
to be if you're black:
I'm a victim.
They wouldn't let me
get the Nobel Prize
because I was black.
I'm an economist. I'm
a damn good economist.
I want the Nobel prize.
I want the Nobel Prize!
They wouldn't let me have
it 'cause I'm black, okay?
That is getting old,
but we need our leaders,
I'm talking about African
American leaders, to point away,
point away from that,
and they're not doing it.
- So let's shift
a little bit back
to the academic part of this
because related to all of this
is the fact that
academic standards
are basically being
obliterated right now
in the name of equity,
in terms of testing,
in terms of, you know
what's happening at Harvard,
where they're actually
punishing Asian students
at the admissions level.
That must, putting
aside the racial part,
just as an academic,
as someone at a place
of higher education,
that must drive you crazy.
- Well, I'm against it.
I signed on to the amicus brief
that some economists
put together
to support the Asians in
their lawsuit against Harvard
because I disagree
with that policy,
but many of us
here in the academy
are full score
behind this stuff.
It breaks my heart,
to be honest with you,
because it's an
invitation to mediocrity,
and it's a kind of bluff
and a shell game.
Here, let me just be clear
about what I'm talking about.
At the very most exclusive
venues of intellectual labor,
like at a Princeton University,
or a Brown University,
or a MIT, or a Caltech,
the stuff is really hard, and
not everybody can do it well.
It's hard.
It's hard reading Plato
and figuring out what
he was talking about.
It's hard doing physics.
It's hard doing advanced
mathematics, and chemistry,
and other STEM stuff like that.
That stuff is difficult.
Med school is hard.
Law school is hard.
It requires real
intellectual mastery
in order to be done effectively.
Now, unfortunately,
a proportionate number
of African Americans
have not achieved that mastery.
Now, we can go into
the reasons why.
History has not been entirely
kind to African Americans.
There's blame enough
to go around. Why?
But the fact of the matter is
a proportionate number, relative
to population, of blacks,
so we're fewer
in the venues where the
intellectual work is difficult.
Now, there are two things you
can do in the face of that.
One of them is to
lower the standards
so that you can increase
the representation
of African Americans
and call that inclusion.
The other is to grasp the
nettle, bite the bullet,
whatever metaphor you want,
face up to the
developmental deficiencies
and address them,
and I mean address them
from infancy, okay?
Now, this is not laissez-faire.
I'm not saying there could
be no government program.
I'm not saying don't
have any education.
Don't have any Head Start.
Don't have any summer
program, whatever.
We can talk about what the
things are that need to be done,
but can we first understand
what the problem is?
If our kids are testing poorly,
it's because they don't
know the material, okay?
If an Asian kid
from a poor family
living in a two-room
apartment with four siblings
can ace the test, our
kids can do it too.
Anybody who doesn't
think so is a racist.
They have the racism
of the bigotry of low
expectation about black.
You write us off? You think
we're defeated by history?
You think we're infants that
we can't actually perform?
We can perform. We
need to do the work.
Give us an opportunity.
Confront the deficits.
Redress them. Keep the
level of playing field.
Don't lower the bar for us,
and we'll measure up in
the fullness of time.
It may not happen tomorrow,
and it may not
happen the next day,
but it'll happen in
the fullness of time.
I say this as a matter of faith,
so I think we make
the wrong choice.
Now, I can understand in 1970,
with all the
rabble-rousing and whatnot,
and the universities
had to meet the protest
halfway and whatnot,
and they did what they did,
but we're now in the year 2021.
We're a half century past that,
and we're laying
down a predicate
for how it is that
we go forward,
and this, "No, it's not
equality; it's equity" bunk
is a surrender in the face
of the problem that we face.
The problem is
develop black people
so that proportionately more
of us exhibit the mastery
requisite to being successful
in these competitive venues.
Did you see what happened?
I rambled a bit, but thank
you for giving me the time.
You see what happened at
the Georgetown Law Center?
The Georgetown Law Center,
this brouhaha from
a few months ago.
A instructor, into a hot mic,
not knowing that she
was being recorded,
allowed as how the poor
performance in her class
clustering at the bottom were
very disproportionately black.
She said it upset her.
She didn't know
what to do about it,
but the black kids
were not doing well.
Do you know what happened
when it was revealed
that she had said this?
They defined Georgetown Law
as a racist institution.
The students demanded, and the
dean acceded to the demand,
that this professor be fired.
White professors
were called upon
to get together and
issue a statement
on behalf of their
white privilege
taking responsibility
for the poor performance
of the black students
in the law class.
Now, here's what I know:
contracts, constitutional law,
torts, civil procedure,
this is what you
study in law school,
that stuff is hard, man.
That stuff will
make your head hurt.
Those big casebooks that you
see people carrying around
and stuff like that...
Writing an effective
legal argument
is a real skill.
What the professor was reporting
is that the black kids at
Georgetown, this is Georgetown,
this is one of the elite
law schools on the planet,
disproportionately
don't have that skill.
Now, you would have thought
that the administration,
being informed of that,
would slap their foreheads,
and says, "Oh my God,
let's do something
"to make sure that our
youngsters who are of color
"have the skill."
No, no, they retreat behind
this institutional racism stuff,
and it's patronizing
and condescending
to blacks to do it
because what you're
really saying is,
"We don't think you're ever
gonna be able to cut it.
"We'll cover for
you. It's okay."
- So as a numbers guy,
and as an economist,
have you ever seen an instance
where equity actually
raises anyone?
Or is it literally always
that the way we get equity
is that you're bringing
down a certain class?
Does it ever do
this other thing?
- (sighs) Well, I'm not
sure how to answer that.
I'm sure I could
find examples where,
if I did a little bit
of leveling and
evening early on,
the opportunities that
I generated for kids
would give them a chance
to show what they can do,
and they might not otherwise
be able to get in or whatever,
but I'm hard-pressed.
I'm hard-pressed to actually
come up with an example,
so I'll just answer no.
- (chuckles) You definitely
can't be president
because you forthrightly
answered a question
that you weren't totally
sure of the answer on.
(Glenn laughs)
You mentioned
reparations before,
and about, maybe about
four months ago or so,
suddenly it was a
very hot conversation.
Now there's a whole bunch
of other stuff going on,
so it seems to have
tempered down a little bit,
but we know it's gonna come
back into the equation.
You're against reparations.
Can you explain why?
I mean, I think it's
a clear through line
to everything we've discussed,
but I wanna let you answer it-
- Well, it's certainly related
to what I've been saying,
but don't do that
to our country.
Don't do that to our country.
Here, so let's be specific.
You know about the Japanese
who were interned by the
Roosevelt administration
in the Second World War,
and they lost their property,
and their businesses,
and it was a horrible thing,
their civil liberties.
These were citizens,
some of them,
many of them, most of them,
so Ronald Reagan
signed into law,
and I think George
Herbert Walker Bush
presided over the administration
of a statute that
recognized the harm,
apologized to those people,
and paid them reparations.
They got 20,000 a head.
There was 80,000 of them.
80,000 people, $20,000 a
head, that's $1.6 billion,
and the people who got paid
were the ones who
got dispossessed,
not their children, not
their grandchildren,
not their cousins.
- [Dave] Right.
- 20,000 a head, 80,000
people, $1.6 billion,
so we could do that, and
we should have done it.
Now, you take African Americans.
We're 40 million.
I don't know what
40 acres and a mule
comes to in the current day,
but they tell me it's in the
tens of thousands of dollars,
so let's just say $100,000 to
be on the (indistinct), okay?
That's $4 trillion
with a T.
The interned Japanese
got 1.6 billion,
80,000 of them.
These people are talking
about trillions of dollars
being, in one way or another,
transferred to
Americans who are black.
That's a Social Security-scale
enactment of public distribution
based on the race
of the citizen.
That's South Africaesque.
We don't want that
for our country.
I don't say that as a black
man. I say that as an American.
We don't want that
for our country.
That's not the way we do this.
Now, if we're concerned about
people who are disadvantaged,
we can direct ourselves
to their disadvantage,
and by the way, I don't
really see an argument
for overlooking a
disadvantaged white person
on my way to helping a
disadvantaged black person,
so what I think the advocates
of reparations should do,
easy for me to say, they're
not listening to me for advice,
is if they want to see more
money spent on schools,
if they wanna see more
money spent on welfare,
money spent on education,
or whatever, on
housing, on healthcare,
put the weight of their advocacy
behind whatever the progressive
political program is
that they think is gonna
deliver that for themselves,
I might not support
every letter of it,
but that's neither
here nor there.
That's for the country,
so that's one argument I
have against reparations.
Please don't do
that to my country.
We're already divided
enough by race,
but there's another
argument that I have
that I think is
just as important,
which is the problems
besetting the black poor
are not gonna go away
when you enact some kind
of statute like this.
I'm talking about the
out-of-wedlock births.
single-parent families.
I'm talking about the poor
reading and math skills.
I'm talking about
the low work habits.
the number of people
involved in criminal activity,
the people who are in the
prisons, and so forth and so on.
There's gonna continue
to be an issue
in Detroit,
Cleveland, St. Louis,
South Side, West Side
of Chicago, et cetera,
and many, many other places
besides in this country.
If you sit down at a
bargaining table with America
and cut a deal,
you cut a side deal
with America for blacks
on behalf of that,
and you get paid,
whatever you get,
that commodifies your
claim on the country
and discharges the obligation.
Now you're on your own.
Next time around, people will
rightly be able to say to you,
"Don't come to me
with your bellyaching
"about this or about that.
"You have been paid."
Why would we do that?
Just from a purely
tactical point of view,
that's not a good play,
so it's bad for the country,
and at the end of the day,
even though it may
not be apparent,
it's also bad for black
people, in my opinion.
- Can I toss in one more?
I'd love to know what
you think about this,
that it also sort of
ignores human psychology,
which is that even if
you did the 4 trillion,
and everyone gets
a hundred grand,
that the progressives
of tomorrow
will tell the people
who accept the money,
"You've sold us
out for that money"
because of what you
just laid out there,
that most likely the
problems don't go away,
and then suddenly the
progressives of 2040 will say,
"Well, either we want more,
"or the generation before us
"was just part of the
evil, corrupt system,"
or something like that.
- Yeah, that's probably right,
and it's probably the case
that they will be able to
get something out of that
if the politics of the
current day is still going on.
I mean, not withstanding the
fact that you've been paid,
you'd still be able to milk
the system for something
based on that kind
of an argument.
I don't know. I can't
think that far ahead, Dave.
- (laughs) Do you get sick of
talking about the race thing?
Because I don't know
how much you know
about me, specifically,
but I was a progressive.
I was a lefty, and then, really,
there was a few things
that woke me up,
but I would say the one thing
that I really shifted on
was libertarian economics,
talking to Thomas Sowell
and some of the other
great libertarian
and conservative economists,
so I could talk to
you about economy,
the economy all day long,
and that would be great,
but of course, we gotta
do some of this stuff.
Do you ever just,
when you're talking to
John on the podcast,
do you ever just get sick
of having to do that thing?
- Yeah, in fact, John and
I have talked about it.
It's in the archives somewhere.
We've had a couple of episodes
where we've just reflected on
why don't we get out
of the race business?
He's a linguist, and
he's a very talented
and accomplished
professor of linguistics,
writes books about the stuff.
I'm a technical economist.
I have the accolades to
show, and so forth and so on,
and we could live
perfectly fine, quiet lives
just doing our thing,
so yeah, we've talked about it.
I even tried it back in the day,
back when I was a
Reagan Republican,
and I was on my
way to Washington,
and I ended up getting
caught in a scandal
with a extramarital affair,
and I got accused of
assaulting a woman,
which I did not do,
but it was the end
of my public career
for that period,
and I said, (sighs) "Let me
get out of the race business.
"Let me go back,"
and I published three papers
in "The American Economic
Review" in one year,
which is virtually an
unprecedented accomplishment
because I put my head down,
and just started
doing my research.
It lasted for maybe
three or four years,
and the next thing you
knew, the events of the day
kept pulling me back
and pulling me back,
and I finally just
stopped fighting it.
I think this is
part of my calling.
It's not the whole thing,
but it's a part of it.
I'm doing some stuff that
relatively few people
will/can do,
and it's important.
I think it's important,
so I've kind of acquiesced
to that being a part of my role,
but I like reading
novels, and philosophy,
and history, and whatnot.
This is not my whole
life, but it is what I'm,
it's the beat that I'm
covering right now.
- So I got one one more for you,
and I think I know
the answer already
'cause you're saying a lot of
this with a smile on your face
and just sort of your
general demeanor,
but are you hopeful that we
can get through this thing
and get back to some
of the principles
that you've talked about here
that you think are the
right guiding principles
for this country?
You think we can
get through this?
- I don't know. I alternate.
Sometimes I'm very pessimistic.
What's happening in our schools
is absolutely fundamental.
I'm talking about K through 12.
I'm saying what
we're teaching kids,
the 1619 Project scared
the bejesus out of me.
That's "The New York Times."
That's a rewriting
of American history
centering it on the
fact of slavery,
and I don't mind, of course,
that we would teach our kids
about the history of
slavery in this country,
but 1776,
1787, the Constitution
being ratified,
man, that is a world historic
creation of a government
under the ideas of
the Enlightenment
with real institutions that
have worked for centuries
and been a beacon to the world.
You don't put 1619 next to 1776
and call it a draw.
That's throwing away the
baby with the bathwater.
That's a disaster
if that kind of idea
gets in the heads of too
many of our young people,
so I think the jury is out,
and I think the battlefield
is K through 12 education.
Critical race theory
in the schools,
now, there is free speech.
We could fight about
creation science.
We could fight about sex
education in the schools,
so I guess we're gonna have
to fight about this too,
but to me, that's ground zero.
- Glenn, it's been a
pleasure. This was overdue.
I thank you for taking the time.
- My pleasure, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.